praise all i have returned from the acid
waters of my ex-girlfriends and finally
have time to cover episode 4. sorry it's
a few days late but as i always say soul
works in mysterious ways okay that
didn't make any sense but i had to come
up with an intro we have a lot to
uncover so let's get right into it
marcus and his team of believers keep
watch for an imminent attack by the
atheist paul was told of this attack by
the quantum computer known as trust and
now he's passing on that information to
his fellow believers but this is all
part of a much more elaborate plan by
the conniving computer you'll notice
paul examining one of these tarot cards
one with the tree symbol if you remember
back to the pentagonal prophecy those
who eat from the tree will be made pure
and there they will build a city of
peace and the prophet will be made its
king paul believes they won't be able to
find this tree because it hasn't been
grown yet the seeds he says are in the
tarantula that giant ship controlled by
trust in episode 1 paul uncovered this
box which led him to believe that the
tree of knowledge needs to be grown
seeds
it hasn't been planted yet it needs to
be grown something is also in this box
which we don't know yet the boys surmise
that this box can only be opened with a
powerful laser paul enthusiastically
volunteers to get those seeds for marcus
just like he helped him get mother's
eyes in season one but what's more
interesting about this conversation is
paul's revelation to marcus that saul
has been talking to him i mean if i
thought i was a prophet and god spoke
only through me i wouldn't be happy if i
found out he was talking to others as
well i would lose a part of me that made
me feel special paul also reveals why
he's forgiven marcus but not sue for not
telling him they aren't his real parents
it boils down to marcus being a believer
and sue an atheist you can't forgive an
artist there's also a line that had my
foreshadowing alarm go off when marcus
says this about sue becoming a believer
maybe she might come around paul's mouse
one he received from trust as a reward
for telling him the whereabouts of the
believers was actually implanted with a
bile bomb a sneaky attempt by trust to
kill the believers without sacrificing
their own men this ends up causing a
violent contagion that covers paul in
some sort of cocoon but before he slips
into unconsciousness we see his pupils
turn into slits almost serpent-like we
do know that trust has been collecting
samples from the serpents so perhaps
they're using these samples to create
new and deadly bio weapons it also seems
that marcus is unaffected by this virus
likely due to mother's eyes which will
later get removed from his stomach
marcus prays to saul to help save his
son while also chastising vril for being
the one to bring the boys to their
campsite in the first place if ril had
never done that paul in all likelihood
would be fine this is all part of a
gradual build-up to pit vril against her
own mother decima campion rushes off to
get help from mother believing her to be
the only hope for paul's survival but
this would put the believers in jeopardy
so decima orders her robot daughter to
stop him it's a move that forces real to
attack campion but because she can't
stray from a direct order she has to do
it a bit of a budding romance has
sprouted between these two which makes
the scene all the more compelling back
at atheist camp father hunter and
tempest relish in their victory over the
industrial droid billy last episode this
one father a can of fuel blood which he
believes will help revive the million
year old android he's been putting
together for the last few episodes
tempest also tells them the guy she hung
out with at the scrap market belongs to
a different encampment one she promised
to give up her baby to you may recall
that tempus child was the result of her
being raped by mithra clerk named otho
father shows hunter and tempest what
he's been working on and relates its
creation more akin to farming than
engineering at first it doesn't seem to
react to the fuel blood but as father
and the others leave it sucks that
liquid right up mother rips apart poor
vita's necromancer game which is what
gives her the idea to use one of its
microchips to control the serpent we see
her testing it on a bird but it doesn't
go over too well sue also questions
mother about the origin of the serpent
knowing that mother is actually its mom
last episode she learned that mother's
pregnancy and the birth of the serpent
line up perfectly in arguably one of the
most wtf moments of the episode campion
is attacked by real only for her to be
attacked by this weird-looking creature
a creature which has evolved to
withstand the acidic waters we've seen
other such creatures on kepler back in
season one so it seems as though there
are different types of species that have
adapted to the planet's various
ecosystems that being said i don't think
one of these creatures has enough
strength to completely pull a giant
container into the ocean on its own so
who knows what else lurks beneath the
acidic water rill's injury does not
allow her to chase after campion like
her direct order stated but something
the show has been hinting at is a
robot's ability to override its core
directives and make their own decisions
when mother confronts trust he says that
it's impossible for him to promise
protection to her children because it's
against his core programming to not
treat everyone equally there are some
out there who believe that trust is
actually saul before he's learned to
override its programming the evidence on
this is pretty thin but it's definitely
possible and as i stated in my episode 1
and 2 breakdown one of the ancient tarot
cards does look strikingly similar to
truss core tamerlane chases after
campion but the two are overwhelmed by
the presence of this giant glowing being
you'll see its outline and shape look
similar to father's android i think this
event will have major implications for
campion who tells mother that he saw
saul this may be what it takes in order
for campion to become a believer
meanwhile back at the believer camp vril
has her face brutally cut to pieces by
her own mother disma has chosen marcus
over her android daughter the scalpel
she uses has been brought up multiple
times over the season and i can't help
but think it'll be pivotal to the story
remember marcus hinted that this scalpel
is actually the sword needed to guide
humanity to the tree of knowledge you
can't find the tree without the sword
that wouldn't be the one with it when
vril thrusts herself over the cliff the
scalpel drops too we've seen in the
previews that vril survives this fall so
if she has this scalpel it may prove
extremely important in the future i've
theorized that this person in the
previews is vril and now that we see her
holding this scalpel i think it's almost
100 confirmed four episodes in and we
get our first major confrontation
between mother and marcus normally an
android would be able to best a human
but since marcus ate the necromancer
eyes near the end of season 1 it's given
him incredible powers including these
gnarly veins and marcus almost kills
mother here if it weren't for champion
in his slingshot it's here mother's eyes
glow from within marcus's body as she
realizes his powers weren't granted by a
god they were stolen from her she'll
take back her eyes and use them to pick
up paul and fly back to the tarantula
sorry champion you gotta take the bus
home mother demands that trust gives her
the antidote to save paul she'll even
wipe out everyone there in order to get
what she wants initially trust has his
men fire at her but when he finds out
she has her eyes back he knows it's in
his own interest to stand down because
trust is unable to provide an antidote
nor promise protection for her children
she has him shut down this causes chaos
among the people with mother later
promising them she will be their leader
and will one day pass that baton on this
was something trust was also supposed to
do well as soon as it decides we're
ready it'll pass the baton and we can
govern ourselves mother has been priming
champion to one day be this leader
marcus returns from his defeat and
notice how his veins have gone now that
the eyes have been taken from him desma
senses that something is different about
him and this is likely that the power
has left him a few episodes ago decima
told him that being around him was being
like in saul's presence but without the
eyes what will happen next he's
powerless and has no direction plus
they're in a zone with a large magnetic
field so it's likely he won't be able to
hear saul like he did in season 1.
father arrives to find his android has
disappeared initially believing it to be
confiscated by mother however a few
moments later we see it floating outside
if you've seen my episode 1-2 breakdown
i've theorized that this is an early
iteration of a necromancer that was
credited on imdb as grandmother and
guess what i went to check again and
that name and actress have since been
removed this light shining through the
door also mimics the intro song the door
that
finally opens with life
with mother obtaining her eyes again and
becoming almost invincible this being
might be the counter to her although we
don't exactly know what her powers
entail i'm also curious what the being
knows about what happened to this planet
millions of years ago are we in some
sort of cyclical pattern where we
destroy our planet repopulate a new one
and destroy it only to return to the
first planet and complete the cycle all
over again no matter how hard you work
to keep them safe mother in the end
who will always destroy themselves over
and over and over again also take a look
at how the being is affecting father's
eyes it's the same circle pattern that
mother experiences while putting in her
necromancer eyes now this could mean a
few things that the being can control
father that father might have
necromancer powers that he's being
rebooted somehow or it could be nothing
at all with only two more episodes left
i really feel the pace of the show is
picking up and i hope you'll stick with
me as i continue to cover the show be
sure to leave your comments below on
what you think will happen next and drop
a like and subscribe thanks for watching
everyone for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember you
cannot be defeated
if we keep our faith